how's gum res mine a spirit pad today
we're gonna play the most badass game in
the history of games
it's called [ __ ] some [ __ ] something
this is a story better fish this is a
story about me
beautiful the story I wish forced to
defend my home from invaders that may
have trouble recalling the specifics but
it went a little something like this
sexy lip stir this is like flappy bird
part 2
hey [ __ ] says ship for I can't [ __ ]
sushi shits she me yes there we go let's
play um a new game wave 1 so I'm so cute
Oh fabulous sharks that's when you know
yeah it's a great game more fabulous
sharks and confetti up here when they
die that's it's pretty realistic I would
say yeah shop time I'll buy um this
thing I have a hatch that's what the
hell oh my god dig the music it's
[ __ ] sweet man did it or should we
buy this banana looking thing I'll get
that one there are no enemies what
what's the point
hardest level ever oh my god I can't
believe we did this that oh my god that
was really good I'm Molly coal ministers
do not microwave laughs [ __ ] you can't
tell me what to not microwave I'm tiny
now screw your fabulous sharks
this is like the story of me if I ever
watch the fish just fine no wait if I
ever was a I don't [ __ ] know I have
three guns because why not
oh god oh [ __ ] oh god okay yeah [ __ ] oh
oh it isn't over yet evildoer Oh God
it's so quick how am I supposed to read
that
let's get me so fast face I can't even
inverted movement Oh God gosh Shea say
y'all you [ __ ] aah
no that can't be right let me try again
alright that's pretty cool actually like
it let's do it again then let's see how
far we can go Brea's oh Jesus Christ
what is happening that boasts me hahaha
amazing cookies for breakfast I love
cookie ID mmm slow now maybe I shouldn't
have this ha come ha ha escape is hard
man I wish I was this fab you're not if
you think you're fab you have not seen
shark fab it's a whole new level it's a
whole new shut up alright yes yes
alright we haven't got hidden so far
candy give me candy
oh god is steering a thanedars to him um
again I didn't know there was thunder
storms underneath the water that's
amazing Oh God I don't know what the
[ __ ] things do and now I should laser
beams amazing no good don't die now
don't die now don't dad oh come on yeah
in your face in your face
stupid beetles alright buddy we gotta
now wave 11 I'm super god I got lasix
this is amazing
I always wanted to be a buff ass fish
shooting lasers in the red cyberspace oh
god that was close [ __ ] huh give me an
item give me a sweet hat or some [ __ ]
I can shoot cannonballs oh my god this
is the high point of my laughs amazing
stupid fab shark I can't for sure you
have every weapon what is it what is
that even app what the [ __ ] stop oh my
god I don't want to die now Oh Oh God Oh
what is happening what am I doing with
my left fish ball awesome what what are
you doing stupid kittens
I knew kittens had something to do with
this oh god oh god it's over oh huh this
game is so hardcore
I can't even I'm so tiny oh god what is
this I know the gerado does [ __ ] met
up boy
ah [ __ ] oh I got him I got him I got him
all right give me something good I don't
[ __ ] know
all right I'm here catch a vet I'm
screwed now oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god we have to kill them math kill
him
ah-ah-ah it's America it's America blue
banana
Oh God I'm so goddamn it it make me tiny
again now oh whoa whoa how am I still
alive new yes yes oh my god
I'll get me an item don't make me tiny
please oh [ __ ] sake oh there's no
enemies I'm so stressed out right now
this game is hardcore man you can't deny
that [ __ ] bring it on
break it up I'm a fish wash okay this is
exclusive solid time
are you barrel gun barrel I got a lot of
them they're a double they're for
[ __ ] I'm dead now I'm dead now it's
over yeah I've never been what you say
I'm not you are a fish
what of course you were [ __ ] you I'm
gonna go guppy [ __ ] it I want to see how
far we can go
Party Time what is going it
I've totally traded hair right now oh
man I never party thought I party by
murdering sharks before give me
something good and you had to makes you
feel ten again I kept shooting pokeballs
are you serious haha amazing oh Jesus
Christ
what oh my god
take these pokeballs oh they do a lot of
damage Jesus and fish ball or I have a
spoon I'll find them tiny oh Jesus look
at dad look at dad dad dad look at dad
dad dad look at that dad dad look at
that dad dad good look at dad dad dad
dad
give me the dragon please forget I can
shoot cat no I wanted my pokeball whoa
this is a high point in my left haha oh
my god
take this book but never thought I play
a game when I'm efficient shooting poke
balls this is this is this is very
emotional for me I don't I don't know
how to contain all these fields all
these field filled fish do you know why
I'm murdering all these fishes because
I'm shellfish that's hilarious
I have three poke ball cannons minecraft
I am done with life all right I just
have to beat this little [ __ ] ah no all
right how many lives I've wear many
lights bridge rapid fire three No ah we
lost her well at least it isn't a kitten
shooting more kittens why would they do
that and what and where can i buy this
submarine make yes the best one warning
what is going on oh my gosh what is
going on I have no idea oh my god no oh
oh oh oh one more time with him
congratulation do you complete a guppy
mode but more chairs are waiting to
normal difficulty son of a [ __ ] ah come
on I don't want to it's too hard deep in
fish bra do you even brahbrah
I bet the final boss of this game is
gonna be Kanye West this is giant
beautiful face on a fish stick
playing Kanye 8-bit music in the
background I'm just saying if that's not
a thing developer get on that oh god I
should so slow now this is impossible
it's not fair
yes I'm getting better man 0:09 all
right let's play some more just for the
halibut as I'm so nervous
this game just makes Oh goddammit Oh
goddammit seriously seriously seriously
what the actual [ __ ] is going on what no
oh I tried so hard to lose it uh Indian
I'm gonna beat that [ __ ] thing
Oh
biking helmet amazing what does it do
though I got my Swedish power on we
should be able to do this give me a good
hat a gentle fish and a scholar
that's India they are also scholars
they're all what Jacobs get out of here
stupid sharks think there's gentlemen
for arms one Bowl whoo amazing take it
there plankton some cheap watch I have
no idea what that is okay baby head no
not shocking now are you cereal oh god
it's ruin my life yes yes Oh
yeah boy Oh for [ __ ] sake Opie laser
beam oh god okay I gotta get gotta get
it
gotta get that boom boom boom okay okay
okay okay okay okay I've had you know
items only but what where's the butts I
was promised but now they are fantastic
thank you so much I am done with life
now oh my god uh Oh God not two kittens
I [ __ ] hate two kittens
only in this game I promise oh god oh
god I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
Oh give me pokeballs please laser poke
balls now I'm so [ __ ] tryharding
right now you bros have no idea yes hold
my face bread I got this shot all right
up cigars that has to be good right now
for [ __ ] sake oh yeah I am
deader no no no don't be over no oh yeah
I'm gonna keep playing I don't give a
[ __ ]
nice add a booger on my face all this
video and you don't even tell me I
thought you were a fab shark man I
thought you were better than that it's
probably the most realistic fish game
I've ever played at least I don't know
about your brothers but I'm really
feeling very immersed right now so that
means it's realistic right I'm pretty
sure all let's go for the game boy Bryce
always awful ha a Game Boy is bad in
this game I don't understand why unless
being slow is good which it isn't come
on baby
flex those nuts for me yeah that's right
I don't know you flex nuts that's
disgusting actually I know how to do it
I'm not hitting on you I got an eye
patch ha ha ha amazing oh my god no oh
this is terrible got it
oh god no no let's play I saw it in a
let's play video what did you see in a
let's play video a machine gun I'm
sweating like a [ __ ] this game
is so intense yeah fat yeah give me a
fancy had a snappy dresser I got an
achievement I mean I have to be immortal
let's try Livescribe res ah one more one
more
I'm so hooked on this game oh man but
senpai still won't notice you ha ha ha I
have every weapon but senpai will still
what noticed me no items only butts
goddamn it goddamn you butts what are
you doing here
why are they wearing sunglasses that is
a real question
I don't know there's a lot of questions
to be honest double speed Oh goddammit
I'm a mouse why did I pick this one for
[ __ ] sake no I hate you mutts yeah
when do we have to go ah I gotta go this
game was really hook hooking me on go
ahead and leave like you know watching
Brea's see if you can beat my high score
I debt which I doubt because it was
amazing they like me door watching
Rafi hushed